I've been answering to a pilot program
dealing with writing across the
curriculum and the genre closer readings
which are used in philosophy balls of
history humanities English things and I
put together a website that's on my
faculty website is the subset which I
can't access because apparently UNC FSU
is considered a dangerous site for not
pewter so you can't see it but I've got
this on there if you go to my faculty
web page you can find links to it so
this is part of a larger project and if
you think about where where professors
typically are during their formation
this is less of a problem now for a
younger professor because they get some
training but for those of us who were
the early end of the Generation X
Generation I know I had a few pedagogy
classes but but you know we didn't take
them that serious what we were
interested in was our research because
that's what you do in graduate school
and so you know this is the kind of
story that was my story and it's a story
of many about other professors
management grad student who had they
been spending their time with other grad
students not with undergraduates
teaching they'd excelled in and enjoyed
learning that's why they were in
graduate school for the big box that it
we're going to and in this case it's
somebody who had been taught about and
you know thought a lot about Plato and
platonic dialogue and I saw something
attractive yet Plato's dialogues they
wanted to study them further in one way
that you get to do this by teaching
classes on another typical experience so
then they started out teaching
undergraduates and beginning level
teachers are put up a full of passion
they know what they want to communicate
and they see something desirable there
and they want to pass it on those too
but what what is undergraduate teaching
like I've never talked well prepared
students I've taught a number of
different places my first time in HBCU
and I've taught in small liberal arts
colleges we prisons a number of places
and I see the same sort of thing come on
the students are often under prepared
for college little work and what are
they left they lack certain basic
lower-order skills that then have to be
scaffolding that would allow adequately
understand platonic dialogues if you
want to teach that's and so what do they
provide us with unless we provide them
with a lot
structure of guidance they give us they
give us products that quite quite
frankly are not up to snuff and often
they seem clueless what they're supposed
to be giving us but that's on the right
what's on our well and I'm sort of
echoing my my co-presenter was saying we
often don't grasp the difficulties their
students or hatter we set our sights way
to and I because we're evaluating them
in importance with our you know people
that we were students with anime expect
students to be motivated I don't think
that's an expectation that we can
actually have and we expect students
have some idea about what they're doing
a lot of the students are showing up to
our classes and saying I have no idea
what I'm supposed to be doing I have no
idea what the philosophy is about all I
know is my advisor so they have to take
this class and one of the traps that
that we often fall into is assuming that
because it was some things were easy for
us to pick up and grasp that it should
be easy for our students we want to move
on to the higher-order skills that
photonic dialogues allow us to engage
with it without realizing that they
don't have the foundation to do what to
do that so active learning katonic
dialogues part why they are a classic at
Cassandra they were one of the original
sites for active learning and they have
been throughout the ages they've been
used pedagogically in a number of
different philosophical and pedagogical
traditions because they model dimensions
of active learning systems they they
require students if they're engaged with
them to provide arguments to assess
arguments and they cultivate the desire
to know to find out what's true
what's beautiful that's what the
dialogues are about quite often the
passive attitude on students particles
is an obstacle and I don't really need
to go through what that passes lifers
we've all experienced these are just
some of its general features you know
some of them it has to do it the way in
which they would talk a lot of them were
given formats in which there's a right
answer wrong answer you throw it out
right away and now you're done they
don't realize that you go on with some
of it is effect hurts where it's
uncomfortable to be thinking about
things as it is often hampers and
they're not going to put a lot of work
they're not going to throw some walk-in
times a few couples if you'll have a
loss resources and this leads to a lack
of responsibility not taking ownership
active learning means that the students
are actually thinking about where am I
going what am i doing in critical
thinking actually one of the key parts
of it in the APA recording article thing
where you're sort of gold standard one
of the elements of critical thinking is
is is attention itself attention to what
one is doing self correction so what do
we do about it one of the things that
I'm going to actually skip over but is
we're thinking about Plato has this
great discussion about why do people
become
santro quick and then why do they become
miss missile logic which means that they
distrust argument well it's because they
set their expectations very high and
there let down over and over again and
so then maybe they come to distrust
misanthropic people distrust over people
this logic people distrust arguments and
we might come to distrust our students
there's a danger of that especially when
we're trying to teach high order
thinking skills and we're trying to
teach great pieces of literature you
know our students let us down over and
over again we may decide well there's
not worth investing ourselves but that's
a failure it's a lack of critical
thinking actually so I think we can take
a cue from Plato's student who is
Plato's key student think back to your
old humanities classes or introduction
philosophy classes who is most important
student Chris with an a great
philosopher Aristotle right this is a
classic picture of Plato and Aristotle
it's often used an introduction to
philosophy text to talk about the
difference between them Plato's
gesturing up to the heavens you know we
need to think about the higher things we
need to take our guidance from those and
the other stuff will kind of fall in
place and it's kind of fuzzy about the
details about how you get from the lower
do that Aristotle is you know sort of
holding his hand out and there's a
difference between pointing and setting
up bases aerosol is gesturing
downloaders so the to the base to the
basics of the lower things and for
philosophers this was not a good thing
right because you know we're interested
in
but if we're thinking about in terms of
Education maybe this is a good thing
what are the gestures tell us so well
you know I'm going to skip through that
a little bit quickly because I'm afraid
of running on time well let's take a
risk you LeAnn approach to the topic
dial a little bit you know going against
trickery so what our platonic dialogues
topic dialogues are written by this guy
who is a philosopher in his own right
has spent a lot of time with other
people who are carrying out really high
orders thinking and it thought a lot
about this and wrote dialogues that are
engaging if you have a tease to them if
you're ready to use them so they're
designed to engage your students on the
hybrid but before our students can do
that before they can stay right close
reading paper that's what the genres of
papers that we often assigned in
literature history philosophy what do
they have to do they have to develop a
lot of lower order skills we can't take
that for granted they have to scaffold
incidents before they even start doing
close readings so I was assigning for
those readings over and over again and
that just being baffled by how my
students worked we're kidding I was
providing assignment sheets rubrics and
I wasn't getting that they just didn't
have so what would I ever stopped us as
lots or aerosol would say look you can't
develop higher-order things into the
other bases you have to actually have a
solid basis to go on and you need to be
able to understand the effective son how
to shape emotions and desires and then
the students also have to have some idea
where they're going you can't just rely
on them to do that
in rishta chilean terms he talks about
impressing 4mon banner or you know
getting the form to peer out of matter
and I think it's a good philosophical
idea for this that doesn't mean throwing
play-doh beside play-doh you know you
still have this desire leading to higher
levels but we have to actually build the
bridges so we can lead some students to
be able to fully in the age of Plato's
dialogues which is one and again think
back to your your introduction to
philosophy classes or humanities classes
what will play those key concepts to the
cave what was philosophy of eating
people out of this cave where they're
they're stuck looking at images and
getting them to see reality we use this
as a metaphor for philosophy but what we
often forget is that this is a step
process in the dialogue you don't just
pull the guy out of the cave and say the
way we're doing movies and will say look
at this and then suddenly it all becomes
clear to them Plato says you actually
have to take this person out of the cave
but they're not going to like it they're
going to be upset with you and they're
going to struggle against and you have
to gradually you know show them things
show them first reflections and on the
water and then you can actually show
them the things themselves then you can
actually show them the thing that's the
source of light you can't do this you
know automatically we're or assume that
it's just really happy by itself so I
think this is exactly what we mean when
we talk about scaffolding skills so then
you might say well why are why are we
going to do this with the talk dialogues
we're going to set our sights lower
maybe we should stick with things that
are easy and there there is some merit
to that but I think that we still should
teach
at least in humanities classes and
philosophy classes in literature classes
why part because beta was part of the
cultural heritage of world literature
what do we want for our students not
just to be exposed to what is absolutely
contemporary but to gain a good
grounding in literature the corpus of
platonic dialogues should they possess
intrinsic value they have students
engaging with arguments they have
students thinking about what is beauty
what is truth what can moral goodness be
taught and there's also an instrumental
or pedagogical value to Plato's
dialogues he constructed them as
educational tools and it's up to us to
harness them now we're going to harness
them in ways what I'm suggesting we
harness them in ways that Plato didn't
intent and I think that that's okay but
ultimately what do we want to lead them
towards lifelong learning and that's
where maybe they can't grasp platonic
dialogues and their fullness in our
classes right now but if we get them on
the right track and we arm them with the
skills that they need and we'll give
them practice in those skills and we
show them that Plato's dialogues
actually are sites where we can cause a
bit maybe then that the book doesn't get
sold back maybe that when they're 30
they reread the dialogues and they get
more out of it oh I simply couldn't give
an example of a little automated
just trying to follow these are some of
the things I think we need to do in
order to promote lifelong learning and
these are all things that are also
discussed not necessarily terminal
scaffolding but things that are
discussed in Plato's dialogues and one
of the things I think we need to do is
think about this exactly is a good segue
what motor skills first of all candy
focused on using Plato's dialogues as
content I'm not assuming that anybody
you know super familiar with those
dialogues your senses some of you have
read them which lower-order skills
should be focused on this is sort of a
question what do they need in order to
get there and that which law order order
skills are the most useful moving
students towards and higher-order skills
would like them to have when they're
studying play that's a war you know
idealistic question maybe our students
maybe most of our students won't be able
to do things like that that highly the
first class with those dialogues but
it's still worth thinking about that
depends I'm going to skip through some
of this fairly quickly again if you want
to see the full present full
presentation it's on my faculty website
section that deals with close readings
one of the ways to practice lower over
reading skills is to take passage in a
dialogue mass and have either you read
it aloud where you have the students
if you have multiple people who are
comfortable with that you get as many
voices as possible reading these these
dialogues one of the things that you
find they have to do is actually figure
out who's talking at which point and
sometimes students are confused about
that and then you stop at different
points and you ask the students to
explain what's being sent in the passage
of all your love now how I want to try
again you devote to that well as much
time as the students need in order to
master that skill of being able to just
stop and say in their own words what's
going on here and there's I didn't put
this into the presentation because
there's a dilemma feels like there's a
risk and do it if we're supposed to be
teaching them how to read Plato and
we're spending all this time on doing
you know very low order it seemed to be
very low order things are we copying up
aren't we giving up on the possibility
of these students being able to to
really engage high-low I don't think
that I think that that's a false dilemma
but that it requires a lot of
coordination in order to make it taken
for it is a true dilemma if the idea as
well which is having to work with these
lower order skills and we spend a lot of
time on that and we don't move towards
these higher-order skills which are
completely discreet from them until
they've got this down those skills
aren't discreet talk about the big
scaffold that means that we're building
from these lower
going from the content that we're having
them engage with to lead them towards
higher skills another thing that I think
is a good practice is identifying the
characters and speech and positions have
the students actually identify who's
saying what speech that takes some
practice plan I've been paper after
paper after paper where the student is
attributing this position of this speech
to this character when it's really this
characteristic so if we don't want
students to do that we have to lead them
through that and actually sit them down
say who is actually talking you're
Socrates with your sentence Socrates or
Orion have a student's determine the
positions now we're starting to build
towards higher skills not just who's
saying what are they actually saying and
see as the students can determine the
attitudes of the interlocutors towards
each other Plato's dialogues are full of
little clues about how each character
feels about the other character I think
that that's that's worth students do I'm
going to skip through to critical
thinking skills perhaps the lower order
critical thinking skills meet philosophy
there are a lot of shorter arguments in
Plato that are built up into larger
islands so you know what do we what we
philosophers usually want to do with our
students we want to actually provide
them with handouts that provide the
whole big structure of the argument and
get our students to grasp those
arguments and that's a failure on our
part to expect them to be able to do
that instead first they have to get this
little argument here as an argument
forget all the rest of the context and
then once they've got that down now they
can get this
right here and then they can start
building them together into larger
blocks it's not just Plato that we would
do this I've used Martin Luther King's
letter from a Birmingham jail for the
same something that's a very large well
structured complex argument that
ultimately has one finish point one
conclusion which is it's okay to break
the law in this case and then there are
all these other sub arguments within
them if we want our students to be able
to do that to be able to understand the
large argument they understand the
smaller of its first so i think it's
okay even if that means that we don't
get to is much material that we don't
teach as many dialects if they get that
stuff down if they see how to do it and
we don't turn them off then later on a
lifelong learning can take place once
you know now they're quick to do it so
what would we have them do with the
shorter arguments first identifying the
main claims that might be something
worth spending half a classic just being
able to identify what's actually being
said we can't take it for granted that
students can do that then connecting the
other claims made by the interlocutors
used to support the first ones putting
premises together with conclusions
reconstructing does the structure and
then finally at only after they've
actually figured out what's actually
being said can they go on to say is it
right or wrong cuz ur bizarre a good
argument here or bad art I get a few
other examples of these grasp of
Socrates examples uses tons of exam
what's going on with those is he really
arguing about shoes and shoemakers or is
he argued about something else that's
that's again that's a lower order skill
that we can practice over and over again
their students that they can then move
towards higher skills so how do we
progress that towards these I've been
doing a lot of thinking about this and I
don't consider this an exhaustive list I
think this would help with clinic
dialogue and I think it would help with
other similar types of literature where
there's an argument involved awful forms
an assessment of the student assignments
so that they're they're getting business
world with doctors